[Music]
I'm Saul Kripke I written various books
on different philosophical mathematical
and even linguistic topics
okay so you've made groundbreaking work
on beat against time how did you become
interested in him in particular I
suppose because I studied for my
undergraduate degree at Harvard and at
least two of the or maybe three come
think of visitor to of the relevant
faculty members were very interested in
Vidkun Stein and especially the later
Wittgenstein you know the investigations
but I didn't really come to me view as
to why this might really be an important
argument until after finishing and in
the following year in 1962 two three
did I uh come on my own take on what he
was doing right why do you think that
that was the regional order different
from the interpretation people had at
the time well some people do challenge
me about this right I myself do think it
was a different interpretation and and
really it was Vic and Stein as it struck
me and presented a problem as I say
right and well do you objected a creep
consign term the people sometimes used
to refer to your interpretation of it
against time no I think it's alright as
long as it isn't as some people say
means it's a denial that I have
understood him correctly at all right
but it's hard for any
to claim that he/she right has got the
right understanding of it huge time
because you know the thing is written
and I mean both the earlier thing and
the investigations are written in some
style that invites one to wonder what it
really means you know in that way it
might be more like a mental philosophy
than like conventional analytic
philosophy but is mostly really thought
to be analytic philosophy anyway about
that in particular using the bit against
time did that you know on purpose that
he was seeking to get that reader to
think on his or her own terms
yeah well that's what he says he hasn't
done this to say things for the reader
but to encourage her him right to think
for herself right and so on right and I
suppose that's right nevertheless in
spite of his saying that he doesn't
state theses in philosophy since
everyone would agree to them he does
seem to be pushing forward certain
issues and problems and so on right some
people have disputed the term skeptic
when supplied to begin Stein would you
have anything to say about that well he
probably would not it of how the term
skeptic in that way you might compare
him to say Berkeley who thought he was
defending confidence and and Hugh Hugh
Max remarked well no matter what he says
right is you sparklies user only
skeptical and I think that might be the
case with it against time - he certainly
raises a skeptical problem I think in
anyway right
and also I you think that his position
ends up being relativistic right oh yes
now and even says so you know like an
uncertainty you know one of my critics
said how could the author of be
uncertainty be an epistemological
skeptic now what I was interpreting him
in my interpretation of it consign
wasn't really epistemological skepticism
but what constitutive skepticism right
nevertheless I think that in fact
uncertainty itself is a highly
relativistic book Ryan says toward the
end so if you find another culture who
instead of consulting a physicist
consult so which doctor was that Lewis
right what should we say I mean if you
were condemning them aren't you going
outside our language game and trying to
fight the other one and that is supposed
to be obviously wrong right and that
certainly is relativism Plus Ryan and
that is related to the question that
ants come asking about yes and even ants
come a follower and admirer right I mean
she she had a piece about this the
question of linguistic idealism I think
it was called but she said she asked him
well what if he had a friend who started
to take up which talk during
would you PM it all embarrassed or
opposed to this right and he is said to
have replied to her well I probably
wouldn't like it but I don't know why
about your own position because in the
book you are presenting between Stein's
view and trying to present them in the
best possible light and but on your own
view what would be your take on the
solution and will you become beans by
either would you tend to these
regardless yeah Wow I do tend to think
it can't be right that there's something
we do which is called grasping a concept
right and that somehow does determine
our answers in the future right but I
mean he's all skeptical argument he's
supposed to show that there is no such
thing so and maybe I think maybe thanks
really we live by a myth as if there
were such a thing right I mean he says
someone undid the grip of unfollowing a
rule right the answer should be well
Ansem translates as a matter of course
but I think the better translation the
answer should be obvious to me right
right to the rule follower and that is
what is the case when someone is and do
the [ __ ] following volscian I think
right yeah okay well thank you very much
so for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of arts
and ideas at iai TV
you